je crois qu'il ya une partie à londres
mais c'est des on-dit
je m'appelle caméra that je fais
comédienne et je suis à cannes parce que
je vais gérer plusieurs marques et parce
que j'ai un film qui s'appelle masqué
madrid et darwin au marché du film
c'est à propos du women for women donc
c'est pour que les femmes aient plus de
places dans le cinéma dans l'industrie
du cinéma dans la production en tant
qu'actrice aussi donc c'est des valeurs
évidemment que je défends
mon plus beau souvenir cannois c'est la
première fois que je suis venu je crois
que c'est la dernière puisque je l'avais
jamais fait donc évidemment c'était un
peu spécial j'ai monté les marches avec
le réal et c'est vrai que comme il son
sponsor du festival de cannes on avait
vraiment le tapis un peu pour nous
puisque hommage et horreur de devoir
pousser les gens pour c'est pas mon truc
donc on est vraiment reçu comme des
princesses
je peux pas choisir je peux pas choisir
j'ai évidemment le cinéma c'est ici
c'est une partie de mon coeur mais la
série c'est aussi l'avenir et moi en
tant que spectatrice j'adore tellement
les séries je peux passer à 8 heures à
bin djaouad chéri donc je peux pas je
peux pas choisir
bref aurélien
way sainte anne avec virginie ledoyen
qui adorent est une drogue
je peux rien vous dire sur la saison 3
des mines paris ce parce que j'ai pas
d'infos je crois qu'à une partie à
londres mais cd ondine
[Musique]
ben que l ena la porte des talons de 12
pour aller au boulot ça c'est pas très
parisien
[Musique]